[Applause]
one for me real good I'm yeah I'm Felix
I'm part of a research group that looks
in what kind of different areas this new
space and fauna speak today about is a
project that we have for ongoing project
in collaboration with the hospital that
we call med space so we analyze all kind
of medical images from damage goes from
CT to my eye to x-ray and we apply
patient deep longing so a little edge
and now we first have to get all of you
on the same level
I will recap a little bit for
probability serious then afterwards it's
a very short recap of deep learning how
it's different from deep learning how to
learn from patient deep learning and
then we go specifically into a messed up
said was I develop a deep mind about
three or four years ago that's called
base buy back prop later on we will look
a little bit into uncertainty because
all the patient deep learning gives us
some kind of uncertainty measurements of
how sure our output is of the network
and then we apply to medical imagery
analysis
yeah it's mathematically quite heavy I
would say but please please stay with me
and there we go like just raise your
hand right if you don't understand
something and yeah we just recap that
okay what are probabilities probability
is something what is uncertain basically
so we have knee bend X and then that
event can either be totally impossible
or it can be totally alone so the
probability of that event X is always
between 0 & 1 it makes it easy we only
have numbers between 0 & 1
ok another fundamental aspect of
certainty on planning is a random
variable so that's it quantity X we
usually say capital X and whose values
answer so that means automatically that
X has a probability theory and the
capital X can then be all kind of
different events what we usually they
say a lowercase X s okay so you might
ask like why do we need that
doesn't make sense to have said all that
but what we do machine learning right we
do predictions we do forecasts all the
time so even when you take the weather
forecast father for the upcoming day we
usually get 15 degrees we get sunny ok
but can it actually be sure can we be
totally sure that is this going to be
tomorrow 15 degrees and sunny I doubt
that we can't be what happens very often
we have rain and probably not 15 degrees
so would it not make more sense that we
actually have a probability that we say
it's kind of likely that we have Sun and
that we have written agrees with
probability of zero point seven point 70
percent but wouldn't it also make sense
to give us some probability of certain
degrees of 14 degrees of 16 degrees of
17 degrees and couldn't it be also that
we have some probability that are
actually raining we don't know right so
another example what we what we worked
on that project is medical image
analysis so we have an x-ray of our
chest and then a doctor saying okay here
we have lung cancer
but can the doctor be actually be
totally sound there are tons of examples
out but the doctor was wrong ruined
basically a human's life gave him heavy
medicine and in the end he was really
healthy
what happened quite a lot so wouldn't it
be actually kind of good inside if we
have some kind of uncertainty
measurement if you just know how certain
actually the prediction is and that is
for patient deep learning does so just
to yeah recap deep learning you've
probably seen something like that before
a deep neural network is simply some
input X what what we have here then we
have some weights or this kind of making
the decision but it's very influential
in the real decision then we have some
nonlinear transformations that is called
Chi and we have feel something or just
like a displayed here that I'm seeing
what's called a sick mind Phi Sigma
Direction what is just nonlinear
transformation and then in the end we
have a prediction that said Y hat what
is nothing else in the Chi of W
multiplied by X and then we have our
output right okay so the W's are the
kind of most influential effect of
interdental only because they actually
saying what kind of
River get in the end and how how
actually a deep neural network is
learning is back replication that's an
algorithm was developed 21 probably more
than 20 years ago by a core by a guy
called Yong Li kun and some other guys
he's now at Facebook and what it Betty
does is to two steps first we measure
the error so we have some kind of cost
function what it's all good error
function loss function you've probably
seen that it's basically we take the
prediction of the network what does it y
hat and then we compare it to a label so
when we give an image of a house we tell
the network that's a house and then we
compare what the network actually gave
out or that the network might have given
out so that does this picture of a house
is a dog but it's wrong so we compare so
it gets some kind of higher arrow
function I'm higher cost and in the next
step we measure how responsibilities
weights our Father for the error and
that is that done by the I'm saying what
is the partial derivative so we take we
take the total cost what is kind of a
number and then we look how responsible
each of the ways right like there's
never only one waiting in the deep
neural net was there always whatever
millions of different weights and then
we look how responsible each of the
weights is for to keep an error on total
and then we update them so we take some
kind of learning rate alpha takes a
weight of the previous step of the
previous iteration we call it and then
calculates a new weight and then we do
such as thousands of time again we kind
of get the weights that said minimize
that error here and then we have more
correct predictions that's all what it's
about okay that was all deep learning
bar yeah what is now Bayesian deep
learning
first of all I severely distinguishing
feature is that we have in a normal
neural networking on the right side we
have six numbers s weights right so just
on the previous slide from the back
propagation we learn these numbers as
weights this number should be then
somehow keeping us giving us many
right predictions in Bayesian deep
learning be don't take a number we take
a probability distribution so you're
probably see in a normal distribution
what is like the bell-shaped
distribution and what the distribution
has you need T to values to learn the
distribution we just take takes a mean
but it's the most likely value bursar
like the middle of that entire bell and
then the other taken variance what is
saying how white is our distribution so
that's like really yeah kind of
interesting and difficult problem
because behavior now these two values
and we want to know and before we had
only one value that makes it makes it
all a bit a bit difficult but how do we
actually learn these distributions there
is something well as a very special
trick what was developed like just two
years ago but makes it all kind of
simple so we have set distribution what
you see here on the right side and
instead of one value we have two values
for this mean what we said we said knew
was that Greek letter and then we have a
variance or standard deviation what we
call a sigma and tens of weights what we
had before a beta disease parameter
theta and yes Isetta is a collection
offset mean and variance and then we
have that weight here again what is now
only one value because we have we have
such function of epsilon epsilon it's a
normal distribution so we kind of hide
our distribution inside of these weight
values but when we later on we recover
that we still have these two values what
what give us a distribution right but we
can do the back propagation because they
only have one value because these
partial derivatives that I spoke about
yeah you can only compute them and you
have one given value and that is that
that weight for so we actually kind of
good with that for that special trick
here okay so all that Bayesian like it's
called patient deep learning right so we
have something that is called Bayes rule
what is what is basically sad so we have
here
the left side it's a probability
distribution of the weights given the
data so that's what we are interested in
right the weights are the
decision-makers of the network and then
we have the data so we want to have some
weight after we have seen all the data
and that is the posterior we call a
posterior distribution let us say 1 we
are distribution we want to know and
that is computed by a prior though the
mean time kind of belief or the main
knowledge it is something like when we
when we have seen some similar data
before we kind of can give the network
already a guess how how these
distributions might look like we
multiply that by likelihood what is the
probability of the data given given the
weight so how well our our data that is
currently represented by by the weights
and then we just normalize it by a data
distribution what it's a bit unfortunate
in that entire setting is that since
data distribution is intractable and I
will explain in a minute for intractable
means such as it simply means that you
cannot compute in any in any for super
time and when we have on the right hand
side of the equal sign intractable like
entity or term the other half is I don't
left hand side right so as I said before
that posterior is actually z1
probability distribution we want to know
but given its intractable it makes
things very difficult so yeah what does
intractable actually mean we have
training that you can imagine you you
can talk about imagenet we can talk
about c4 100 so in c4 100 we have we
have hundred different classes each
class has whatever 600 images although
and these could be images of houses so
you train the network with 600 images of
house but what do you want in the end
you want to go around London take a
picture of a house and you wanted that
the network is able to give you an
output that's a house right and that
that image of the house in London is
probably not part of that of the data
that for to train also you're going to
want to have some kind of hi all some
kind of hang out pattern of a house and
that each house in the world can be
actually recognized by
by the network so our training that is
only a small part of the entire data
distribution that PFD would mean we have
data or we have the data that from all
houses in the world and then can have a
precise precise knowledge of the data
distribution but we don't have that so
we only have little sample I get some
kind of examples of the entire
distribution that that is what it means
when it's interactive but we don't know
it exactly and that will all be never
possible because it's just totally
infeasible to take pictures of all
houses in the entire world okay let's
get back to that we have here we have
the interact ability here also
interactive belongs to let left hand
side but what we want to focus on this
now the posterior because that's exactly
what we want to know so when we don't
know how something can be computed
exactly we have in statistic million of
approximation methods so we do
approximations here you can understand
us a true distribution what I said P of
the posterior P of W give indeed looks
maybe something like that and then we
have basically two big families of
different methods and one method called
variational distribution or variational
in Firenze what means we place a second
distribution on top of the true
distribution and then kind of make these
two somehow looking similar or we have
Monte Carlo methods what means we take
random sample from the true distribution
and then when we have taken millions of
samples you might have some guests how
the true distribution actually looked
like since the Monte Carlo methods are
really difficult for complicated
distributions because like in a deep
neural network these distributions are
usually very very complex and
multi-dimensional and so on B takes a
variation distribution because it's much
faster and that's actually what we were
to speak today about about the entire
entire variation inference so yeah just
to get us on the same level we have the
true distribution the blue one
usually called P and then we have a
variational distribution what we can
learn what is that that red one the Q
and the user here the parameter theta
again what is nothing else and the mean
and the variance of the distribution so
what we do is simply ballon mean of the
variance of every weight and we then
have a min the end that we have it's
somehow similar so we find this
parameter theta so to find the
distribution Q what makes Q somehow
similar to P I'm also giving you some
graphical intuition because I know I
know it's fairly it's fairly complex so
you can understand there's Q all the
possible values that theta can take in
which define the Q are given by them
space and so the true distribution P is
very unfortunately out of that space
what means we can approximate it but we
can never be exactly how the true
distribution and then we start we take
some initial values for theta very often
we just take mean 0 variance 1 because
it's called standard normal distribution
and somehow works kind of kind of well
but we want to like learn over time
right we train the network for millions
of iterations and thousands of epochs
until you actually get somewhere very
close to the P and we do that by so we
then kind of fun to make P P similar to
Q and there's something what is called
the KL divergence what is what clear
back light or divergence which is kind
of measuring how similar these two
distributions are we call it divergence
you can see it as a distance or even
just it as a difference of these two
distributions so we have to carry out of
options and then we actually want to
minimize that error versus that we
arrive finally at an optimal optimal
values for theta which make Q very
similar to P but just is I'm destined
some difference between those so we can
never be exactly the same okay let's go
into that Caleb I'm just explaining it a
bit
how it's calculated looks it looks all
complex but you don't need to understand
it and send in detail bodies as one very
interesting aspect is that we have our
integral here so an integral you can see
has an infinite infinite long some right
and then when we actually come to
compute that in fact long term we can't
again we can't determine if you can't
calculate it exactly but because it's
infinite and you've been able our answer
for that so we have here some
intractability again what yeah what we
do very similar stuff then before we
need to approximate it again there's
some more mathematics you can see that
as a II what means expected value of
that entire boxing here in the brackets
but that's not important so we find
these optimal values we have then an
optimization problem because we have
that argument what means we want to find
some minimum some minimum values for
theta which which makes that which makes
it a as small as possible and these are
optimal values because when these when
when we have C set down Q is very
similar to P okay we can rephrase it no
need to worry about that we have some
constants that we can kick out and all
but all that rephrasing doesn't make us
Matt doesn't make too much sense because
we still have a intractability so J is
what based by back probe comes in like
there the problem has been there for I
don't know for 20 years probably and
people just didn't know how to handle
that intractability and was
statistically very hard problem but then
some really bright minds at Eve might
develop something what is called base by
backdrop and what they do here is
actually combining these two big
families what I what I spoke about
earlier so we have set variational
distribution right what I said set bail
shape here on top of the true
distribution the blue one but since the
K Arabic losses interactor but we can
take or we actually go around it by
taking some samples from that from that
red distribution so we combine variation
in Firenze it with Monte Carlo and then
people call them Monte Carlo valuation
and friends or they just call it base by
backdrop
what all that thing is doing is having
here a Sam sign instead of integral so
because we take these samples we have
actually a yeah a Feeny number of
samples that we take and not that
integral what is basically infinite
number so we take now see samples and we
can actually just hard code in our
algorithm how many samples we want to
take and then we can actually get to
some kind of good approximation so you
know all that intractable what we what
we have seen before is all basically
redeemed by pass at some sign what makes
it all yea feasible ok but we still
speak of probability distributions and
as like the very first slide when I
define probability it's something what
is answer and event X that has some kind
of uncertainty but what does that
uncertainty actually tell us they are
two kind of different different
uncertainties what's epistemic in a
rhetoric you don't need to focus too
much on down on the terms but it simply
gives us some insights what actually
sees uncertainties can can do so when it
comes to predicting we have separate
ones that we spoke before right and what
we have here that P of Y star Kevin X
star is just the distribution of a new
input so a house what we haven't seen
before and then we gave we have a y star
what is the prediction of set reset
input and we don't have a label to that
because of our predictive distribution
so we have set variance and that
variance is simply it's the sum of the
electric and the epistemic uncertainty
and what you can understand these
different uncertainties it faces that
aleatory
is the data that cost so you have you
can see there's some noisy data that
right so you have whatever let's save
600 pictures of houses and this house
look all very different it's very hard
to run
for deep neural network to find actually
some high-level pet on what a house
looks like so that is those are called a
lottery consultant team and then we have
a second one that's a piste emic and
that is a model based or model cost
uncertainty so when you have let's look
at again at image net in which is
something like 40 gigabytes oh it's a
huge state at that and then we take we
take a CNN a deep neural networks that
has maybe two hidden layers each layer
has 400 units other so naturally like
when you have some kind of experience
with deep neural networks we know that
it's probably predicting horrible if you
maybe get a get a and yeah accuracy a
validation area see what means the right
predictions of my bizarre to 40% for
this extremely low but then we have when
we do the patient deep learning we have
an epistemic uncertainty for bill be
extremely high and it gives us at the
same time then some kind of knowledge
that we need to need to make a more
sophisticated model and probably
increase the number of layers increase
the number of units and at at whatever
sure okay so we applied all the to
medical image analysis what we did was
we took some mi eyes it took some CT
recordings some ultrasound and some just
a simple x-ray so it was all in
collaboration with with the hospital and
they gave us for example some some
images from my assignment like the
people who are from our group from
Newell space didn't really have an idea
of time or any kind of medical images
but then we work with the doctors
together and they that like sees kind of
areas are kind of distinguishing if a
patient has item or not it's usually a
bit smaller when the patient has
Alzheimer and then in image where there
are other patients no Alzheimer's these
errors are usually big bigger so we
simply detect right we have an input a
we have an input P and our network
should simply detect if there's
Alzheimer interred image or if there's
no channel and so given that entire
in top of entire page and deep learning
we have probability of our time also if
image s has actually all-time if we talk
now about the image a here and then we
also have some some uncertainty
measurements so what is it what was like
full of that exam just really good we
have a really high certainty that image
actually contains Alzheimer but it would
be just phenomenal right if or it is
phenomena that we have they do have a
probability distribution here because if
that is fairly low we we know actually
that we maybe need a different model to
to have an output or we maybe need a
second opinion from a doctor and so on
so we don't have that totally
deterministic output often neural
network anymore we have a probability
distribution what makes it what makes it
somehow more more insightful so we
worked on an item of detection we also
worked on localization what means we
have these bounding boxes we just gave
the network so task to actually find so
distinguishing features of the brain
that is saying if there's item a yes or
no and then it actually found by itself
so the are C's exact areas what the
doctors anyway told us what was just a
really good confirmation that's a
network it's looking at the right place
that's right and then we have again a
probability of the box and yeah
automatically sees uncertainty
estimations okay so be versus brain MRI
then just in the beginning to like kind
of get a feeling how medical images work
we worked on a data that does actually
on take off so you can just play around
with it what is not malaria detecting of
the atom human cells that have some
parasites which means malaria malaria
yes and we have some uninfected four
means malaria no and then we played a
little bit around with different data
that so we took all the data we only
took half only photo and basically
looked at season zmt estimations because
you can already guess when we only have
25% of the data the data that is kind of
noisy because it's difficult to see some
high high level patterns what means that
a litera consumed is automatically high
compared to the one
so this hand present it's it's much
lower just to get some yeah it was
basically for us to play around a bit
and get some feeling of in which range
we can expect values then we also look
in chest chest x-ray or lung diseases
I think specific it was lung cancer what
they looked here and then we actually
apply foes be that please give us a box
and please give us detection yes or no
so we found that area have again
probability of the box and these
uncertainty estimates that was all I
hope it was not too heavy
yes actually I will I will take
questions of course
so tune in space we are the combination
of different kind of research
institutions as élémentaire I people
there are German readers sent of
artificial intelligence empirical it's
ETH and we kind of look of all kind of
different projects and people who want
to talk
[Applause]
so I thank you very much for that and
we've got time for a couple of questions
nicely a couple of hands shooting up
already
Felix oh and you've got mics in front of
you and there's a button on the mic push
the talk and then all maybe we have to
wave it Dan dangly make the mics work
please no shout loudly interpreting
probabilities what is not my experience
but in might be and then he asked if we
have any experience with that right so
we've worked on that project with a
whisk and fell out Indian hospital was
in India doctors were not said better
interpreting probability we see our
output just as a second opinion right we
don't want to replace a human it's a
human in the decision-making but just to
give him because it's yeah like they are
always not enough resources to look
properly at an image even though you
have like a massive massive position in
your hands as a doctor right so we see
that as just a second opinion for the
doctor and like after or whatever one
two hours of bit explaining about
probability say by actually quite fine
that's a lady
we the question was what kind of data
that we use how where we got the data
from interested in general the data that
so we started we set data that on Cagle
what everyone can download what is I
think not too big maybe half a gigabyte
or so five megabytes I don't know how
many images are but we just wanted to
explore the possibilities of like we can
take any data that right because it's
algorithm behind doesn't matter or it
doesn't care if you have medical images
or if we have if you have houses but we
just took that medical images analysis
the medical image data that for what
Boston care just freely openly for
download and but then we use the data or
the images we got from that hospital
what way as an MRI images CT we got some
maybe some ultrasound images and what
was any x-ray normal x-rays yeah we we
gave in the beginning we had we had
doctor saying on that image is on that
image is cancer there's no cancer so we
gave some kind of training set and then
but that was only for for given amount
and then everything else was unjust
yeah what's done by the time by
algorithm couldn't give these
classifications or predictions sorry
Bobby was carrying on that conversation
in the brain let's take one more
question yeah
very roughly can talk a little bit about
what processing technique you use before
feeding the neural net with the images
yeah we do something like V has image as
JPEG or PNG I can't remember but then we
had some data augmentation so we flipped
image a little bit we rotated 408 just
flipped it over what else did we use I
think we cropped it randomly so we
artificially made our data that bigger
right so
then like you first take apart from the
left top of the image what might be them
going on but then you take as the second
one it's still the same image but then
you take the bottom right part of the
image and you have actually already two
data examples of one out of one image so
yeah so we take yeah
[Music]
okay
because image is 2d already and then can
we just do today it might have done some
people's I think yeah so I can imagine
there could be lots where I know there
were lots more questions there are many
hands up we haven't got time for those
right now
Felix sir will you be around at the pub
office at the end of the evening so
Felix will be here all evening all
evening folks
just keep piling questions over and
buying beer and saying thanks or cokes
or whatever it might be but say thanks
to our speaker we'll take a break
shortly there'll be an announcement from
aho in a minute but first of all let's
just thank thank you